for the last 10 months police officers
staff and volunteers across the uk have
been out
policing their communities they've been
doing their normal role of keeping
people safe
and fighting crime but they've also been
playing their part
in defeating coronavirus by ensuring
compliance with the various restrictions
that we've all been living with from the
outset we did this in the way that we
always police
working with the public and using common
sense and discretion
in most of our daily encounters it's
been enough to engage with people
to explain the rules and to encourage
compliance
the majority of the public have worked
with us and i thank them for that
but a stubborn number of people have
refused to abide by the regulations
and we have had to use enforcement
powers up to this point
as the home secretary has said across
the whole of the united kingdom
we've issued almost forty five thousand
fixed penalty notices
and for that i make no apology
it's very clear that we're now at the
most dangerous stage of the pandemic
there is a real and present risk that
our health service could be overwhelmed
and people our friends and family could
die needlessly from this virus
so we must all play our part in stopping
that from happening
ten months on the rules are clear and i
urge everyone to abide by them
with a virus spreading so rapidly
through contact with others
we should all be asking ourselves
whether our reason to leave home
is truly essential those personal
decisions are critical
since october we've been guiding our
officers to move more quickly
to issuing a fine where people are
clearly breaching regulations and
they're not listening to us
and in most cases the person will comply
after one request
but there are still too many who are
choosing not to
and in doing so they're endangering us
all
and so it's important for me to be
really clear at this critical time
we will have more officers out on
dedicated patrols
to take action against the small few who
are letting us all down
and let's remember each of those
officers is putting themselves at risk
in order to keep people safe and to slow
the spread of this disease
and that's why it's so disappointing to
see some of the irresponsible behavior
that we are having to deal with and let
me give just a few recent examples
a boat party in hertfordshire with more
than 40 people
who paid 30 pounds each for a ticket
a minibus full of people from different
households
traveling from cheltenham into wales to
go for a walk
and in surrey we issued a ten thousand
pound fine to the organizer of a party
who was trying to claim that it was a
business event
and we're also preventing dangerous
breaches
in bristol at the weekend we arrested a
19 year old man
after finding an advert for an illegal
rave on social
media even in somerset police prevented
that event from starting
issued fines to 38 other people who
showed up
and turned away many more we will not
waste time trying to reason with people
like this
who have no regard for the safety of
others
organizing parties or large gatherings
is dangerous
selfish and totally irresponsible in
light of the current threat that we
face organizers will be fined
but so too will the people who choose to
attend
not wearing a face covering on a bus or
a train is dangerous
it risks the lives of other travellers
including those critical workers
who must continue to use public
transport to do their important work
so on those systems unless you're exempt
you can expect a fine
the police service across the uk is
doing all it can
to support the many many people who are
making daily sacrifices
to protect the health of their family
friends and communities
and as more people act sensibly and stay
at home
we will still be visible on your streets
and continuing the work
that we've been doing throughout the
pandemic to keep you safe
our successful staged enforcement
approach remains
but we will not linger on encouragement
for those who are choosing to break the
rules
the rules are clear and we need to abide
by them if we are going to protect the
nhs
and save people's lives